what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so to help you on your
journey today I'm going to talk about
the seven ways to self-promote as an
entrepreneur so one of the things I get
asked a lot by entrepreneurs is how do I
get my name out there how do I promote
myself how do I draw attention to myself
because a lot of entrepreneurs are not
type-a personalities a lot of them don't
want to put themselves out there and be
a name they're nervous they're shy
they're scared and so today I'm going to
share with you my seven ways on how to
self promote as an entrepreneur we
number one is to just believe in
yourself a lot of entrepreneurs just
don't have enough self-confidence and
self belief in what they're selling and
what they're doing I used to do these
events at a big bookstore here in Canada
called chapters and we would have
hundreds of people show up in this event
and one of the exercises that I would
have them do is find somebody else in
the room understand what their business
was and then network with the other
people in the group to find three leads
to help that person out so find one
person understand their business and
then talk to everybody else in the room
and don't come back until you've found
three people that can help them and
everybody did it everybody was able to
find three leads to help that
entrepreneur new friend of theirs but
they weren't willing to do it for
themselves that's a really funny part
they were willing to step up they're
willing to be courageous they're willing
to go and talk about this new person who
they had barely met and promote their
business but if you say go and do this
for yourself they weren't willing to do
it because we don't have enough
self-love we don't believe in ourselves
enough to get out there and actually do
the promotion and so none of the
techniques that I'm going to talk about
today are going to help you until you
believe in the product and for me it
just comes down to knowing that the
thing that you do is valuable and
remembering the customers that you're
helping out remembering the clients that
you have served and how happy they are
to work with you trying to channel that
and funnel that when you're on stage or
when you're at a networking event or
when you're talking to a new potential
prospect
no in the deepest part of your heart
that you provide value and that you can
help and channel that belief into every
conversation that you're having way
number two is tell your story this is
the way that you beat the big guys a lot
of entrepreneurs we have our websites we
have our social media content we have
our messaging that we put out there and
we want to look professional and that's
great you want to look professional but
too often entrepreneurs get way too
corporate
and then I can't tell the difference
between your website and your offering
in some big corporate offering and if
the corporate has a big brand name and
everybody knows that when they've the
reputation and the history in the client
base and you're just starting up or
you're smaller and we don't know much
about you then what's the reason that
I'm gonna pick you over the big company
that I already know the reason is going
to be your story this is how you win as
an entrepreneur and that doesn't mean
don't be professional and don't try to
have a great image of yourself it means
tap in to the thing that makes you come
alive and why you started this business
I firmly believe that every single
entrepreneur needs to have a page on
their website that tells your story why
you started this business why it's so
important to you a foundation story that
when you look at it you get inspired
like yes that's why I do it ideally you
can make a video ideally you can get in
front of the camera for a minute and
tell your video and share it but if
you're too camera shy you can't quite
get there yet at least show a picture of
you and write out a couple paragraphs as
to why this business means so much to
you because this is how you beat the big
guys this is why I'm gonna pay more to
work with you then go somewhere else
because I believe that you will serve me
because I believe in the passion that
you have for starting your company and I
want to work with somebody who cares if
I cannot tell the difference between you
and the big company I'm gonna go with
the big company every time because they
have the reputation tell your story
[Music]
way number three is used social media
it's never been easier to reach your
target audience because social media
makes it so easy to get out there and
connect with multiple groups and so I've
been looking at reverse engineering
where are your customer spending their
time all your customers on Facebook are
they on LinkedIn are they on YouTube are
they and Instagram or are they on
Twitter are they on Pinterest where are
your customers hanging out and then go
there marketing 101 is be where your
customers are if all your customers are
going to this crazy rock concert then
you want to be at that crazy rock
concert wherever your customers are is
where you need to be and so across the
different social media platforms your
customers are hanging out there are you
a part of the conversation the first
step to having success in social media
is just tracking your name to see if
anybody's talking about you and then
tracking important terms important
conversations that your customers care
about and then being a part of the
discussion it's not going on social and
just selling your stuff it's about
helping people with problems you're an
entrepreneur you solve a problem or at
least you should if you want to have
success you have to solve a specific
problem go to social media see who has
those problems that are talking about it
and then go and answer help them with
their questions they're gonna look you
up they're gonna see what's in your bio
they're gonna check out your website and
they're likely gonna buy from you if
they love your offering so use social
media to find new customers hey guys
it's Marcus here the affiliate marketing
dude and today I'm bringing you step
number four on how to promote yourself
online as an entrepreneur you see the
best way to promote yourself online is
to go out there and find your perfect
customer okay if you are like a
self-help person or a lawyer or a banker
or maybe you're just selling products
online you want to find the perfect
person that fits that mold now what
you're gonna notice is that the perfect
customer is kind of expensive to get
let's say that you are a tax attorney
and you want people that are struggling
with their taxes so that you can help
them right that would be your perfect
customer now what I like to do is look
at that and say well you know the
perfect customer is someone typing in
tax attorney now since that's so obvious
it's very expensive so what I do is I
go back a little bit and say who else
needs what I have to offer who else
needs what I have and you might be able
to find people who are looking up
certain tax forms right and you can find
this using the Google Adwords Keyword
tool and there's all kinds of people
looking up tax forms and what I found is
there's actually some tax form I think
it's like nine nine five four or
something right and that tax form is
actually for people that are looking for
payment plans with the IRS now you can
actually bid on this word or make a
little video and put it on YouTube and
talk about this form talk about how to
get a tax plan with the IRS and become
an expert in that field there's actually
thousands of people every month that are
looking up that form now I can get this
traffic really easy with YouTube or with
search engine ranking or even I could
get this traffic for like ten cents on
Google Adwords so now I'm getting people
very cheap and they want what I have to
offer and they can be my perfect
customer now this works no matter what
industry you're in no matter what you're
doing online all you have to do is go
back a step and learn how to find your
customer who doesn't know you exist yet
that means a customer before they
actually need your product exactly like
this tax form guy he needs your product
he just doesn't know it yet so how can
you go out there and find people who
need your stuff but just don't know it
yet thanks again for watching I hope you
enjoyed this tip if you want to check
out more stuff you can go to my channel
affiliate marketing dude here on YouTube
back to you Evan
[Music]
when number five is bringing value to
others you should be a known quantity to
the important people in your industry
and so I look at my channel as an
example people reach out to me all the
time wanted me to promote their app or
on their website and promote their new
business share with my audience and most
of the time I say no one because I
actually have to use your thing I have
to actually be a active participant and
a customer before I will recommend it to
my audience but mostly I say no because
I don't know who you are I like working
with people who are known quantity to me
yet there's gonna be a lot of people who
comment on my videos who share all my
videos and I know who they are because
they're sharing everything because every
time I put out a piece of content
they're replying they're giving it to
their friends they're tagging people
they're responding and so for those
people if they ever needed anything from
me
they'd have a shot I'm gonna say yes I'm
gonna at least take a look at that email
because I know it's coming from somebody
who I know like and trust and so before
you reach out to influencers before you
reach out to people who have some
authority who if they recommended your
thing you'll be able to explode your
business make sure you were bringing
value to them first make sure you are
known quantity to them before you reach
out for an ask so I did this at the
start of my youtube channel I wanted to
work with collaborations with different
youtubers who had a bigger audience than
me and the first two I did it with was
Tim Schmoyer and Derral Eve's
and these guys have great YouTube
channels if you want to learn how to run
a successful channel I would go
subscribe to them immediately and check
out their content I wanted to do
collapse with them but before just
straight asking I was an active member
of their community I commented on every
video that they put out I followed them
on Twitter and responded some of the
tweets that they put out I tried to
share information and messages that I
thought would help them and not just
great video right that doesn't really
mean much right go go in detail share
some knowledge tell them how it really
made you feel tell them how you really
learn from it I did that over a couple
months and then I reached out and I said
hey Tim I'd love to do a collaboration
with you here's what I think I could
bring to your channel and he said yes
and that was my first collaboration and
I've done it with Tim four or five times
they've done it with Derral at least
once and a bunch of other people before
you reach out make sure you are a known
quantity to that influencer
[Music]
way number six is form alliances so this
ties in really well to the last point
about the collaborations you want to
find out who are the people who already
have access to your target market both
online and offline so whatever it is
that you sell those customers are buying
from other people too not competing
products but related products look at
the buying cycle who are people buying
from before they buy from you and after
they buy from you those are the people
that you want to have some introductory
talks with go meet them say hi follow
them on social media
try to line up a coffee meeting at their
local business and get to know them
because what you want to do is have them
recommend you to their clients that
you're both serving the same market but
you're selling different products and
services and so make that list start
reaching out and it's one of the fastest
ways to be able to promote yourself and
grow your business because instead of
selling one customer at a time making
that one connection to the right partner
they can introduce you to hundreds or
thousands of potential clients for your
business and Wayne number seven is be
the expert you're an entrepreneur you
should be good at what you do right you
should be one of the world's leading
experts in your industry and if you're
not then you need to hustle harder
because it's hard to really bring a ton
of value if you're not an expert and so
understand what you are potentially one
of the world's greatest experts at and
then start sharing that perspective so
you can go to social media and share
your opinions and comment on things that
are happening in your industry you could
speak at different industry events and
be seen as that expert on stage you can
make youtube videos and other content
talking about again things that are
timely to your industry that when people
are caring about it they're going to go
to Google or go to youtube and search
and they're gonna pull up your content
that's gonna lead to a result you can do
old-school-style make PR lists reach out
to reporters look at industry magazines
anytime a reporter is writing an article
on a certain topic that's related to
your industry you want to reach out to
that reporter and give your two cents on
it as well because the next time they
write an article they need an expert
you're making the lives of these
reporters easier because you are an
expert opinion so they don't have to go
out and find somebody else and then they
use you again and again and again in the
game and then they refer you to their
friends and their colleagues in the
media's
and so super important that you take
that knowledge that that expertise have
been built up over how many years of
running your business and put it out
there so that whenever anybody's talking
about your industry you become the
person that they come to for the expert
opinion and advice and so I would much
rather speak at the front of a stage to
my target audience and then have
everybody come up to me afterwards
wanting to work with me then me trying
to go one by one trying to pitch them
and how great I am and it starts by you
sharing your expert opinion across all
the platforms thank you guys so much for
watching I love to know from you which
of the seven ways most resonates with
you which one you're going to
immediately apply some out to your
business leave it down in the comments
below did I miss an eight nine or ten
that you want to add to the list I would
love to hear from you thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple cool it's core value not
one drop of most self-worth depends on
your it's something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details